as we arrive in mikolayev there is panic
a russian warplane is suspected of being
close by
people are told to find immediate
shelter
soon after
the air raid siren sound the alarm
across the city
my hands are shaking i can't eat i can't
drink i just want to stay alive
the only things that keep me strong is
my family i have a small child i want
him to live under a peaceful sky
i don't want to live in another country
i want to live in my motherland i am
ukrainian
is the front line in the south west the
last stop on the road to the strategic
city of odessa ukraine's biggest port
mikolai ever seen fighting for weeks but
this is strike at the heart of
governance here it used to be the civil
administration building but now in times
of war we're told it's also being used
by the military
this morning at 0-850 there was a strike
on this building there are fatalities
and injuries to people pulled alive from
the rubble they have different levels of
injuries
rescue workers are still looking for
survivors
inside the building the attack happened
just a couple of hours ago now the civil
administration building severely damaged
now mikolaiv has been fighting back a
russian assault holding back ground
forces for weeks now but this city
has been severely damaged
and there's psychological damage too
romance avgorodny takes us to his flat
he fled to mikuliv a few days ago from
the russian occupied southern city of
garcon around 60 kilometers from here
i woke up and was making a coffee i took
the cattle then the building started to
shake i was confused
i just started to run around the
apartment then i understood what was
happening so i started to film from my
window i saw the smoke
the moment of impact also caught on a
security camera
mikolav has been praised for recently
managing to push russian ground forces
back but this is an ever-changing front
line
we're told it had been relatively calm
here over the last few days
but as always with war everything can
change in an instant
stephanie decker al-jazeera and
mikolayev southwestern ukraine